so continuing our discussion on the
various Iron Man armors within Marvel
Comics
we pick up now with March 21 through 40
so the mark 21 debuted in Black Panther
vol 3 issue number 44
during the five part story enemy of the
state where the event revealed the Black
Panther had joined the Avengers to spy
on them and also revealed that he had
set up a series of dye corporations to
hide the fact that he owned
ABC wire and cable the company used to
install fiber optics in Avengers mansion
and start tower because of this T'Challa
knew the strengths and weaknesses of
every iteration of Stark's Iron Man
armor dating back to the mark 3 as a
result when stark advocated to chala be
expelled from the Avengers and
confronted him about this information a
battle ensued revealing that the chala
had not only provided himself with claws
capable of piercing Starks armor but
also programmed a back door allowing him
to temporarily disable it while the
story went on to become somewhat of a
clustered mess involving the future
duplicates of the u.s. President
Canadian Prime Minister and even
T'Challa himself in terms of the mark 21
the armor was developed explicitly for
the purpose of facing black panther
head-on without having to worry about
his anti metal claws or ability to hack
the armor to this end the March 21 was
designed as completely non metallic
using a kevlar polymer weave and bio
circuits allowing for the same
functionality as a normal armors without
any of the electrical or metal
components in addition to this because
white Panthers technology and Wakanda
was so advanced this suit was also
designed to compensate by redesigning
the stealth capabilities allowing the
mark 21 to
my Black Panther including his enhanced
senses night vision infrared and light
the suit also had a cloaking device to
hide from the naked eye as well as noise
reduction jets and internal air tanks
allowing for struck to breathe without
putting off any external indication
moving on to the mark 22 this armor is
more commonly referred to as a Thor
Buster armor debuting in Iron Man vol 3
issue number 64 during the three-part
story standoff during the events
peasants and Slovakia had developed a
religion around Thor which was quashed
by the nations government resulting in
the peasants execution because Thor had
been functioning his ruler of Asgard
after Odin's death against the fire
demon Surtur when Thor was informed of
the peasants executions by Heimdall he'd
returned to earth for the purpose of
punishing the nations army
during this time Ironman was contacted
by the federal government and sent to
intervene creating a standoff between
the two over fear that the horse
continued rampage would lead to a third
world war against Thor and as Asgardian
forces however in the midst of the
conflict dr. doom intervened by speaking
with IO man directly revealing that at
some point in the past Thor had given
stark a material of unknown origin which
was claimed to tap into the power of the
odinforce and composed of the same
material as Thor's hammer called room
metal using it as a central power source
sort developed the mark 22 armor for the
purpose of allowing him to do battle
against Thor on an even playing field
regarding his capabilities like the
Hulkbuster armor Thor Buster was
designed for brute force more so than
energy projection to this end where it
did contain repulsors and a uni-beam the
armor itself is powered by the odinforce
making it an even match for the power of
Thor and even allowing stark to stop me
all near mid-flight transitioning to the
mark 23 this armor debuted in Iron Man
vol 3 issue number 71 and is another
armor designed by stark for the purpose
of space exploration however where
previous versions were designed in an
identical fashion to his normal armors
with the exception of some force field
or jet enhancements because adepts of
space are dangerous and the mark 20 had
been destroyed by an alien race start
design the mark 23 to counter this
problem regarding his capabilities the
mark 23 uses honeycomb shaped polymer
tiles meaning that if the exterior of
the armor is damaged by an external
force another piece of armor rises up
and takes its place maintaining the
armors integrity while simultaneously
serving as chaff which can be thrown out
into the face of enemies in addition to
this because it was designed more for
defense and exploration where the mark
23 does contain the standard run of
repulsors and a uni-beam it also
contains diamond tip blades for cutting
through any materials - adamantium and
vibranium as well as a bio containment
fuel to keep samples protected from
exposure to anything which might cause
contamination
moving onto the mark 24 a common
misconception is that this armor debuted
an Iron Man vol 3 issue number 73 but
actually appeared in issue number 78
during the 4 part story the deep end
coming out of Starks appointment to the
position of Secretary of Defense
following the house of M and leading up
to Civil War as a result there wasn't
really a major conflict that
necessitated the design of this armor so
much as it was simply starch desire to
create something new regarding its
abilities the armor is pretty standard
in comparison to the other designs like
the previous models the mark 24
contained repulsors a unibeam sonics and
concussion blast but also use zero-point
energy now to clear this up zero-point
energy is a principle of quantum physics
and represents the leftover energy of an
object when the temperature is absolute
zero which is to say when all matter
stops moving in addition to this the
armor used voice commands allowing it to
enter battle mode and reform itself on
Tony Stark as well as extended repulsor
field over allies for protection and
shut down all of the other Iron Man
armors by remote override something to
note here is that with a mark 24 was
destroyed an Iron Man vol 3 issue number
83 it was replaced by the mark 25 in
issue number 84 but there was virtually
no distinguishable difference between
the two and that they were effectively
identical now following the March 25 can
the extremis armor while it is
considered the 29th model because March
26 through 28 only appeared once or
twice for use as experimentation with no
fuel deployment those armors simply
served as fill-in rather than anything
of real value as one of Starks most
popular suits the extremis armor debuted
an Iron Man vol 4 issue number 5 during
the sixth part Story extremists and this
event a stark industry subsidiary named
future form had been developing a
duplicate of Abraham Erskine Super
Soldier Serum during which time they
developed extremists however while in
the midst of the project future farm
scientists Maya Hansen discovered the
federal government intended to stop
funding their research and alongside
aldrich killian sold extremists on the
black market as a result while working
to retrieve the extremis technology
Stark was injured in a battle with the
villain Malin during which time he
subjected himself to extremists which
began to rewrite his DNA to this end
under the benefits of extremists run of
them physically stepping into a suit the
Iron Man armor was essentially part of
Starks physical body you
mental commands start can immerse
himself in the extremis armor using its
memory metal design meaning that
extremists can regenerate the armor
itself as well as starch physical body
should either become damaged in addition
to this the extremist technology allowed
start to access all satellite networks
security systems and digital
technologies while also piloting the
armor remotely alongside several other
forms of armor for the standard load out
of repulsors a uni-beam cloaking and
sonic remain shields deflectors and a
neural net allowed stark to counter
mutant powers as well as copy them to a
degree furthermore the extremis armor
allow for enhanced flight for speeds
over six thousand miles per hour but the
downside of all this was that without
the extremists drug the ability to
utilize the benefits of the extremis
armor were nearly impossible
now following the extremis armor k march
30 to 34 these armors debuted in Iron
Man vol 4 issue number 7 however while
these suits were designed by stark they
were never designed to be used in any
field capacity and actually existed
outside of the start automatic shutdown
protocols where the armors did activate
after the son of Johansson took over
Stark's weapon systems but was
assassinated by Nick Fury aside from the
armors being powerful enough to require
the combined efforts of the Fantastic
Four and Iron Man to take him down
there's not really any information in
the comics indicating what it was these
armors were capable of moving to the
mark 35 this was a hydro armor developed
by stark that had only appeared once
during Wolverine vol 3 issue number 45
as part of the Civil War conflict
allowing Wolverine division name of the
Submariner in his home world of Atlantis
the mark 36 armor debuted in World War
Hulk number 1 following banners return
to Earth after the events of Planet Hulk
because banner was so powerful due to
the fact that he was in his angriest
form to date the mark 36 was essentially
an upgraded form of the Hulkbuster armor
and that rather than relying on strength
only the suit also contained anti gamma
radiation nanites designed to force folk
back to his human form however because
those have been tampered with the
purpose of the armor was effectively
rendered useless allowing Hulk to subdue
Stark along with the rest of the
Illuminati transitioning to the mark 37
this armor debuted an invincible Iron
Man issue number 25 and began the
process of leading up to the superior
Iron Man armor coming out of Dark Reign
which centered on Norman Osborn taking
over 4 start following his ouster as
director of shield at the events
conclusion Osbourne attached stark and
beat him into a vegetative state where
this led into Stark disassembled Pepper
Potts was informed by a hologram of Tony
that he had previously backed his mind
up and like a computer Tony could
effectively be rebooted using the most
recent backup electing to act on this
information for and Bucky Barnes reset
Tony leading to him coming out of a
vegetative state but with no
recollection of recent events viewing
his life as a fresh start
Stark's ought to have his armor reflect
this by designing a new suit modeled
after the extremist technology but taken
to the next step regarding its abilities
the mark 37 uses the extremis design of
keeping the armor inside Starks body and
only coming out when mentally commanded
but rather than simply taking on the
form of Ironman armor and acting
accordingly
this suit is actually composed of nano
machines powered by an arc reactor on
the chest capable of allowing the nano
machines to reshape themselves into
clothes other armors people as well as
heal both the armor and Stark himself in
addition to this the armor is capable of
reshaping the limbs into weapons limited
only by Starks imagination and include
guns laser cannons and the like
furthermore other than the repulsor is
being located only on the palms they're
also located on the knuckles the chest
the back and the legs of the armor
moving to the mark 38 this armor is more
popularly known as the Phoenix Buster
armor and debuted in Avengers vs. x-men
number 5 once the Avengers became aware
that the Phoenix force was returning
however rather than destroying the
Phoenix force as was intended when stark
used a disrupter it resulted in the
Phoenix force being split among cyclops
Emma Frost named war Colossus and magic
turning them into the Phoenix 5 the mark
39 armor debuted an invincible Iron Man
number 517 during the five-part story
long way down as part of this story
Mandarin in Ezekiel Stane the son of
Obadiah Stane began deploying a series
of revamped armors around the world
attacking various territories because
Stark had also found himself subjected
to a series of corporate espionage
attacks at the hands of hammer
industries these incidents combined with
the Mandarin tricking the media into
believe in its start was still a drunk
led to the US government forcing star to
install a government-sanctioned device
that could shut down the Iron Man armor
remotely
and so in an effort to for Sasha and
Justine hammer the daughter and
granddaughter of Justin Hammer as well
as the Mandarin and Ezekiel Stane into
the open and defeat them start
engineered a plan to resign from his
position as Iron Man and appoint James
Rhodes in his place using a newly
designed suit of armor that was not
under the control of the government
regarding his abilities the mark 39
didn't actually have anything new that
didn't previously exist in either the
war machine or the Iron Man armors and
that it did contain the standard load
out of repulsors Sonic's and a uni-beam
would also contain the ghosting
technology of the war machine armor
allowing the suit to face through solid
matter
finally the mark 40 armor made his debut
and invincible Iron Man number 523
towards the conclusion of the long way
down storyline where James Rhodes was
employed to operate as Iron Man in such
place Mandarin can secretly been
developing a series of Titan Omega
armors of his own with the help of
Ezekiel Stane
however because Danes knowledge was far
from Starks Mandarin had taken over the
mind of stark and forced him to build
the Titan ohmic suits but following
their completion it was revealed the
stark had found a way to combat the
mandarins mind control and working
alongside Ezekiel who had turned coded
as well stark developed the mark 40
using scraps similar to his original
armor as a means to defeat the Titan
Ament models and escape the Mandarin
regarding its abilities because the
marked 40 use limited supplies its
physical appearance reflected the shoddy
materials and his creation but maintain
the technological advancements of Starks
most recent models to this end where the
mark 40 did contain the standard loadout
of Iron Man weapons in the form of
repulsors a uni-beam Sonic's and
concussions the suit was also capable of
interfacing with swarm a series of mini
computers designed by stark resilient
the renamed Stark Industries at the
conclusion of siege when Osborn was
ousted and start turned his attention to
developing less violent technologies
using his ability to tap into swarm the
mark 40 was able to form a giant
repulsor cannon which destroy the Titan
MX suits
defeating the Mandarin and allowing
start to escape with that being said
we're going to bring this video to an
end I hope you guys enjoyed it and I
will catch you guys later peace